what vladimir putin called a special
military operation was in fact his
declaration of war on ukraine
russian forces struck from the air and
on the ground and from all directions
ukrainian cities were bombarded
civilians killed and tens of thousands
panic-stricken ukrainians began flooding
across all its borders i knew by gta i
mean the russian soldiers they kill
children she says they bomb schools
[Applause]
at first it looked like russia would
swallow ukraine and decapitate its
government putin and others thought the
capital keeve would fall within days it
was a gross miscalculation
the ukrainians fought back supported by
arms and intelligence from nato even
sinking a major russian warship
putin also underestimated president
vladimir zelinsky who many thought would
flee
a leader for institute we are here said
zielinski with other government leaders
becoming a symbol and inspiration to
ukrainians and zielinski motivated
nations around the world to help global
leaders came together and much of the
world united to stand up to russia
analyst marcus colga says vladimir putin
misjudged ukraine the west and even
russia's military capabilities i think
he overestimated himself his generals
that uh surround him and the ability of
his forces
putin has told russians all is going
according to plan but one more strategic
failure is plain to see
the brutal invasion of its neighbor has
caused other neighbors sweden and
finland to prepare to join nato russia's
goal of keeping the western alliance
away from its border is backfiring
spectacularly the last 100 days have
demonstrated that when the west stands
together we have a chance to fight back
against these sorts of authoritarians
but for all that has gone wrong for
russia there are no signs that putin is
losing his grip on power that he can and
will fight
on in the first 100 days ukraine has
withstood an onslaught and if the next
100 become a grinding war for territory
one question looms what would each side
accept to bring about peace
eric sorensen global news toronto